bonjour bienvenue à la semaine verte
dans un passé pas si lointain
l'environnement était loin d'être une
priorité l'industrie avait les coudées
franches et pouvaient complètement
détruire un écosystème au nom du
développement économique l'exportation
de l'amiante dans la région de ted
friedman en offre un exemple éloquent
même si la dernière mine a fermé il ya
bientôt dix ans des montagnes de résidus
menace toujours la santé de certains
cours d'eau pourtant des solutions
existent pour restaurer les anciens
sites miniers
[Musique]
on dirait des volcans qui déchire le
ciel
un paysage puissant est rude
nous sommes pourtant bien au québec dans
la région de chaudière appalaches quand
on regarde les deux chimistes avec qui
on voit tout ce qui était fait dans le
passé six de ces images là bas c'est
fait pour l'environnement table un
panorama façonné pendant plus d'un
siècle par l'industrie de l'amiante une
menace à la santé et aux ligues lourd
sur le plan environnemental
on était la capitale mondiale de
l'amiante et puis on en était très fier
et mais il n'y a pas eu de recherches
nécessairement être scientifique sur
l'amiante pour désamorcer cette bombe à
retardement et redonner aux paysages son
aspect naturel des solutions existent
verdir
reboiser valoriser les résidus amiantés
mail détourner la rivière
un chantier titanesque
depuis la fin du 19e siècle
l'exploitation de l'amiante contribuer à
l'essor et à la prospérité de la région
elle fait travailler cinq mille ouvriers
tlf humain devient l'un des plus grands
centres d'exploitation et de production
d'amiante au monde
en creuse partout on démolit même cette
église pour dénicher l'or blanc des
cratères émergent
des convoyeurs crash sans répit des
montagnes de résidus
[Musique]
certains de ces monticules contiennent
des stériles miniers à faible teneur en
fibres d'amiante
d'autres plus toxiques constituées de
résidus miniers fin contiennent de
l'amiante et des métaux
mais dans les années 30 un lien tenu
secret par l'industrie est établi entre
l'amiante et le cancer du poumon
plusieurs autres études scientifiques
confirme ensuite la toxicité de
l'amiante ce qui marque le déclin de
l'industrie
[Musique]
les premières mines ferment leurs portes
au début des années 80 la dernière en
2012 et l'industrie laisse derrière elle
800 millions de tonnes de résidus
amiantés c'est un passé historique qu'on
a eus daltin qui a fait que la ville et
et de ted friedman et escales et
aujourd'hui
on est pris avec quelque chose qui était
faite par quelqu'un d'autre qui est
parti vers une exploitation qui était
fait et des profits qui sont faits
les gens sont plus aujourd'hui des
amoncellements atteignent jusqu'à une
centaine de mètres de hauteur c'est ce
qu'on appelle des ald
aujourd'hui pierre alexandre bergeron
daou et sandrine des oignons prennent
des échantillons d'eau dans la rivière
bécancour
il travaille pour le groupe de
concertation des bassins versants de la
zone bécancour le gros becs
la présence de la rivière au coeur de
ces vestiges de l'ancienne mine british
canadienne les préoccupe c'est la roche
été concassés pourrait libérer les
fibres d'amiante
ça a été entassées comme seul le pendant
est
d'aider glané d'exane d'année mais sans
mesure de de contrôle des eaux de
ruissellement le problème vient de
l'érosion des ald les eaux de pluie
c'est cool en surface forme des
ravinements et en train des particules
de résidus miniers vers le pied des
collines des nappes d'eau peuvent aussi
se former à l'intérieur des ald l'eau
s'écoule puis ressurgit à l'extérieur et
il arrive que des pans complets de al 2
décroche parfois sur plusieurs hectares
comme glissements de terrain
il ya dans la région plus d'une
cinquantaine de halde
elle couvre un territoire de 1500
hectares au milieu duquel coule la
rivière bécancour
une quinzaine sont instables ou très
abrupts comme celle de la bretèche
canadienne elle charrie d'énormes
quantité de sédiments tout droit dans le
cours d'eau donc c'est des sols à nu qui
décroche ou qui sont emportés par les
eaux de ruissellement la fonte des
neiges vers la filière bécancour on voit
des fibres d'amiante et c'est à l'oeil
nu on en voit qui sont accrochées sur
les airs le bord de la rivière
en 2020 un rapport du bape le bureau
d'audiences publiques en environnement
sur la gestion de l'amiante et des
résidus mini dévoile qu'il n'y a pas eu
de contrôles de la part du ministère de
l'environnement le document à l'effet
d'un électrochoc
le bape constate que le ministère n'a
pas réalisé de suivi périodique
il n'a pas documenté l'effet des halles
de résidus miniers sur le milieu
aquatique
et il n'y a pas non plus d'informations
disponibles sur la toxicité de l'amiante
chez les organismes aquatiques
impossible donc de brosser le portrait
précis de la situation
aucun suivi a été fait ni par le
ministère de l'environnement elle ni par
aucun autre ministère il n'y a pas eu il
sans plus avoir de préoccupation
par rapport
à ce qu'on voit ici finalement
pourtant les premiers résultats des
analyses de l'eau prélevée en aval du
secteur minier sont troublants il
confirme que les taux de fibres
d'amiante dans la rivière dépasse
largement la norme américaine
au québec il n'existe pas de normes sur
la présence d'amiante dans l'eau
la menace s'étend aussi au delà du
secteur des ald dans le bassin versant
de la rivière bécancour en direction
nord ouest
elle touche les tentateurs le lac à la
truite le lac william et le lac joseph
les chercheurs olivier jacquet renner
pjanic ont voulu savoir si les ald
nuisent à la santé de ses plans d'eau
ils ont d'abord mesurer les propriétés
physico-chimiques du lac bécancour en
amont des sites miniers pour les
comparer à celles des lacs qui se trouve
en aval ils ont fouillé les entrailles
des plans d'eau en prélevant des
carottes de sédiments
ça nous renseigne sur des écosystèmes
aujourd'hui devenu complètement
différent des écosystèmes qui ont existé
de façon naturelle sans impact humain à
lille il ya quelques quelques dizaines
plus qu'une centaine d'années
les chercheurs vont analyser la
composition géochimiques des sédiments
déposés au fond des lacs
premier constat les résidus miniers des
ald voyage sur une longue distance
les sédiments sont transportés par la
rivière bécancour à partir de ted
friedmann zh ils voyagent à travers
différents plans d'eau de la région
jusqu'au lac joseph
une course d'environ 25 kilomètres
autre constat les algues sont alcalines
ce qui fait grimper le ph de la rivière
bécancour et des lacs en aval
les sédiments contiennent des métaux du
magnésium du chrome et du nickel
donc ça peut changer carrément les
organismes qui habite le milieu
puis ça peut parfois la plus grande
toxicité de certains métaux donc ça peut
avoir une forte répercussion ça peut
avoir des conséquences sur la vie
aquatique des lacs puis se répercute et
surtout la chaîne alimentaire présent
dans les lacs en lisant incidents ces
sédiments on comprend mieux l'histoire
de l'exploitation minière de titres rim
ait
un récit qui nous plonge dans les années
50 avec la découverte d'un important
gisement d'amiante sous le lac noir
pour l'exploiter l'alex best-of québec
prend les grands moyens elle détourne la
rivière bécancour qui alimentait le lac
pendant quatre ans un dragueur retire et
des places la boue du lac noir le lac
noir a séché devient alors la mine lac
d'amiante un gigantesque puits
d'exploitation à ciel ouvert
aujourd'hui la destruction du lac noir a
des conséquences désastreuses pour les
plans d'eau situés en aval de la rivière
on voit que les lacs reçoivent
énormément beaucoup de sédiments depuis
les activités minières et la vidange du
lac noir par exemple
le phénomène est visible à la sortie de
l'étang stetter quelques kilomètres en
aval de la mine un petit barrage qui
devait capter et retenir les sédiments
amiantés n'a pas été entretenu si bien
qu'aujourd'hui les coulées de résidus
amiante et s'étendent vers le lac à la
truite et même au delà vers le lac
william un important centre de
villégiature
donc ça ça fait en sorte que les lacs en
aval sont en train tranquillement de
disparaître donc s'il s'ensable donc ils
se remplissent de sédiments donc la
plupart de la profondeur de la piste
percée
lentement mais sûrement
toute cette matière qui s'accumulent
transforme les lacs en milieu humide et
l'urgence d'agir elle est réelle parce
que si on ne fait rien on laisse tout
comme
actuellement on va assister à un
vieillissement rapide de ces lacs les
sédiments vont s'accumuler rapidement
incluant le contaminant et à travers le
temps ces sédiments là deviennent des
bombes à retardement
qui vont encore accentuer le
vieillissement et la contamination des
eaux
depuis 1995 la loi québécoise sur les
mines oblige un exploitant a restauré et
réaménagé les sites miniers à en prévoir
les coûts et accompagner son plan de
restauration d'une garantie financière
mais dans la région de tête froide il
était déjà trop tard
parce que je pense que c'est important
pour la ville de trouver une façon de
gérer ces battles parce que son lot on
peut pas s'en cacher on partout dans la
ville on les voit
ça a pris 130 ans le créer ces montants
glane extrayant de l'amiante des fausses
c'est des humains qui ont construit ce
cd coups de pic puis de pelle puis des
convoyeurs puis des voyages de camion
puis ça s'est fait au fil des ans donc
ça peut se défaire au fil des ans
c'est possible si humainement possible
d'un petit morceau à la fois à mais
ça prendra volonté
[Musique]
l'image est saisissante
depuis des décennies ces résidences du
quartier black lake à 4h minds sont
encerclés de halle de résidus minier la
santé publique interdit aujourd'hui
toute manipulation des monticules situé
à un kilomètre au moins des résidences
on veut ainsi éviter que la population
soit exposés aux poussières d'amiante
ironiquement à ted friedmann la moitié
des maisons se trouvent à l'intérieur de
cette zone tampon
quand on joue dans des sédiments comme
ce cas de l'amiante que l'on se le
cachera pas et à tous les problèmes de
santé sécurité au travail
si la façon c'est de les valoriser mais
tant mieux si la façon c'est vraiment
laid rêver gtlds et puis après ça se
ressent
sur le site de l'ancien lac noir le
puits de la mine lac d'amiante dépasse
les 400 m un paysage qui est en train de
se métamorphoser
depuis quelques années on assiste à une
grande opération cosmétique etc
l'entreprise viridis qui en est le
maître d'oeuvre
spécialisée dans le recyclage des
matières résiduelles veridis a le mandat
de reverdir les ald de stériles celles
qui n'ont pas de potentiel économique
sébastien hu dirige le chantier son
objectif est de faire d'une pierre trois
coups embellir le paysage
réhabiliter le sol et limiter l'érosion
des ald
on avait donc sur le bord du chemin qui
nous amène sur ce plateau ici on avait
un fossé est relativement important qui
générait beaucoup d'érosion et petit à
petit en revitalisant zone par zone on a
été capable de limiter l'érosion pour
faire en sorte que le fossé n'existe
plus
faire pousser mais végétaux dans ce
paysage aride et tout un défi
[Musique]
le magnésium est toxique il faut le
contrer avec un apport en calcium puis
on doit fabriquer un sol fertile d'une
trentaine de centimètres d'épaisseur à
l'aide de matières résiduelles
fertilisants avec le mélange qu'on
apporte l'ange de sols faiblement
contaminée de résulter d'ancrage et de
boer n'arrive à balancer en fait le
ratio magnésium calcium et ainsi
favoriser la disponibilité de certains
éléments notamment du phosphore pour
favoriser l'implantation des graminées
[Musique]
mais viridis veut aussi y implanter une
forêt et pour sa l'entreprise a recours
à l'expertisé de nicolas bélanger si on
est pour développer de nouvelles
plantations devra se trouver un endroit
lucky qui est mieux drainer je
proposerai d'ailleurs peut-être un site
peut plus se rendre au plateau
en 2018 son équipe à reboiser le site
avec des arbres à croissance rapide des
peupliers hybrides
[Musique]
aujourd'hui les arbres font déjà près de
deux mètres de haut
[Musique]
les arbres au début son sont très petit
avec un très très petit diamètre et l'
on le voit que le diamètre est
significatif après 3 ans et quand même
c'est quand même impressionnant comme
résultat
trois autres essences d'arbres ont été
plantés
des mélèzes des pins et des épinettes en
tout dix mille petits arbres ont servi à
reboiser le site de l'ancienne mine
d'amiante nicolas bélanger a opté pour
des essences dont la génétique est
adapté aux conditions hostiles
les plantations sont fait se rendait
c'est à dire dans des bandes de terre au
surélever la technique double la
profondeur du sol permet aux racines de
mieux se développer et aux arbres de
s'ancrer plus solidement surtout qu'il
vend beaucoup au sommet des collines
[Musique]
oui
à quelques kilomètres de là le lac aux
eaux turquoise de l'ancienne mine
bretécher canadienne 1 est bordée de
flan de stériles mini verdoyant
depuis 2015 la firme englobe un
végétalisée 70 hectares de stériles et
la vie reprend
en une fierté on a vraiment du chevreuil
est arrivé ce matin 7h30 très tôt il y
avait des dons servent à régler des
petits qui jacassent attrait moi parce
qu'ils approchaient trop et puis il y en
a dû aussi des orignaux à les insectes
des abeilles
pour réaliser ce projet englobe à
utiliser près de 700 mille tonnes de
matériaux destinés à l'enfouissement sol
légèrement contaminés boues municipales
et à pothières compost copeaux on y à
semer une prairie de graminées et de
légumineuses et 14 mai l'épinette
blanche une espèce indigène ont été
plantés avec les stars il est important
de faire quelque chose puis la seule
chose qui semblait adéquat c'était des
rebelles et alizée comme vous pouvez
voir les résultats sont probants l'on
prévoit continuer sur je pense à faire
partie du legs de nos sociétés envers la
région
mais selon les compagnies minières les
autres halde celle formée de résidus
miniers ressel peut-être un trésor une
richesse qui pourrait donner un nouvel
élan à l'économie régionale ce qui se
trouve derrière nous ce sont des risques
du mini amiante et qui possède environ 1
30 à 40% de magnésium il ya aussi du
zinc du nickel et toutes sortes d'autres
produits stratégiques qui sont
importants qui ont une très grande
valeur sur le marché les métaux légers
comme le magnésium sont en forte demande
dans l'industrie automobile et
aérospatiale
la société asbestos estime que le
magnésium qui dort dans les collines de
résidus miniers aurait une valeur de 400
milliards de dollars
l'entreprise négocie avec des
partenaires en vue d'en faire
l'extraction et la commercialisation
pour aller chercher de magnésium mon
doigt dynamite et on doit creuser on
doit faire une mine est à l'heure
actuelle nous c'est déjà sorti c'est
déjà miné s'est déjà amusé grande partie
et c'est déjà broyer
il resterait à construire une usine de
production de magnésium dans la région
une usine semblables magnola a vu le
jour au québec en 2000 mais le marché du
magnésium s'est effondré et l'usem à
fait remis trois ans plus tard les
procédés de transformation étaient
vivement critiquées pour leurs rejets
toxiques
aujourd'hui la société asbestos prétend
pouvoir développer des technologies
sécuritaires et propre
mais pour minimiser les risques
sanitaires et environnementaux de la
valorisation des résidus à tête free
minds il faut des règles claires or le
ministère de l'environnement tarder à
lui précisé il faut que les orientations
soient prive pas sa fausse soudain un
jeune con non qu'on a passé à travers le
bureau d'audiences publiques en
environnement fqe la valorisation de ces
matières le qui en a toujours pas de
retour
à savoir comment qu'on peut faire la
valorisation si on peut le faire comment
on peut le voir
dans la tente les investisseurs restent
frileux
et sans ce financement la société
asbestos affirme qu'elle n'a pas les
moyens de décontaminer ces anciens sites
miniers à partir du moment où on a un
projet qui va rapporter des dizaines
voire des centaines de millions de
dollars bah là on a les moyens de faire
des infrastructures pour protéger
l'environnement protéger la rivière puis
protéger les gens si vous demandez de
faire se présente mais là ça devient
compliqué parce que on a personnels et
moyens
mais les projets de valorisation des
résidus miniers ne sont pas possible
partout plusieurs halde très abrupte son
temps passé le long de la rivière
bécancour et sont difficiles d'accès des
pentes sont en rupture d'équilibré
l'ingénieur miroslav chaume constate que
c'est difficile d'intervenir sans
risquer des normes épanchements de
sédiments dans la rivière
[Musique]
où était ce qui se passe je montre que
sédiments ici c'est surtout la cdm enfin
qui tout de suite se retrouvent après
dizaines de mètres dans la rivière
[Musique]
l'association de la protection du lac à
la truite à donner à l'ingénieur le
mandat de protéger la rivière bécancour
et ses différents lacs miroslav chaume
propose une solution radicale sur le
site de l'ancien lac noir
avec un premier ouvrage de dérivation il
ferait bifurquer les eaux des crues et
une portion de la rivière vers le puy du
lac d'amiante l'immense réservoir se
remplirait en quelques années sans
altérer le niveau des autres lacs puis
grâce à une autre canal et le
retournerai long du puits directement
dans la rivière mais je ne vous la zone
chargé de sédiments avec la qualité
d'eau discutable la livre au lac il ya
comme un temps de séjour ou de sédiments
même les sédiments très fin qui sont
d'ailleurs le plus dangereux pour le coc
systèmes aquatiques plus d'opposants
l'ancien plus d'exploitations servirait
donc pendant plusieurs décennies
d'immenses bassins de décantation les
sédiments transportés par la rivière
irait se déposer dans les abîmes du puy
à l'exutoire une eau des charges et de
sédiments minier ressortir est
relativement propre irait ensuite
rejoindre la rivière
plusieurs projets sont sur la table à
dessin
scientifiques et industriels semblent
prêts à travailler en collaboration pour
restaurer les anciens sites miniers j'ai
l'impression que tout les astres
s'alignent pour qu'on puisse travailler
suffisamment de gens intéressés à
trouver des solutions innovantes réel
fonctionnelle et sécuritaire
mais ils disent tous attendre un signal
clair du gouvernement québécois et
surtout l'appui du ministère de
l'environnement je comprends pas que
c'est par le ministère qui entreprend
les travaux ici
l'instance qui devrait être main
d'oeuvre de l'aménagement
ici
nous avons demandé à plusieurs reprises
au ministère de l'environnement de
commenter la situation
dans un premier courriel on nous
confirme que le ministère n'a pas
d'études actuellement en cours sur la
rivière bécancour et on nous renvoie à
l'organisme du bassin versant gros becs
puis dans un autre courriel on précise
que les recommandations du bape sont
actuellement en analyse par les
ministères et organismes concernés et
qu'un comité interministériel a été mis
sur pied et a pour mandat de travailler
sur un plan d'action
toute demande d'entrevue a été pour
l'instant refusé là on est dans une
situation d'urgence on vit ça fait 40
ans que c'est comme ça cinquante ans 60
ans ça d'homère criant comme situation
faut utiliser d'autres d'autres visions
faut qu'il y ait une volonté politique
de dire ok on fastrack lampions ont fait
quelque chose pour contenir l'hémorragie